in a previous video i talked about how a
two by two matrix can be used to define
a transformation for the entire
coordinate plane what we're going to do
in this video is experiment with that
little bit and see if we can think about
how to engineer two by two matrices to
do some of the transformations that you
might be familiar with like rotations or
dilations or reflections
so this is a website run by the
university of texas
web.ma.utexas.edu and you have the url
here i encourage you to go there and
play around with it yourself and what i
have here is i have our two vectors
which any point on our coordinate axis
can be defined by some combination of
these two vectors this in red here is
the vector 1 0. it goes one in the x
direction 0 in the y direction and you
can see that is this first column right
over here in this identity matrix and
this blue vector right over here this is
the vector 0 1 which is the second
column in this identity matrix it goes 0
in the x direction and then 1 in the y
direction
now the way to engineer
a transformation is to say well what
would that transformation do to these
two vectors and then change the numbers
accordingly so for example let's say
that we wanted to have a
reflection about the x-axis
so if you did a reflection about the
x-axis this red vector would not change
it would stay 1 0 but what would happen
to this blue vector instead of being 0 1
it would be 0 negative 1.
so in this transformation matrix if i go
from the identity matrix here but
instead of 0 1 i now it will no longer
be the identity matrix if i put a
negative 1 here and when i press enter
this should flip this blue vector over
the x-axis and essentially flip
everything else with it so let's try
that out i'm going to press enter
and there you have it that cute little
golden retriever is now flipped over so
that met our intuition so let's go back
to what we were doing before so that's a
reflection and you could think about
what would you do if you wanted to flip
the other way across the y axis
now what about a dilation
what if we wanted to shrink everything
by a factor of two what do you how do
you think we would modify this matrix to
do that pause this video and think about
that
well if we want to scale everything down
what we would want is each of these
vectors and especially just by a factor
of 2 we'd want each of these vectors to
be half as long so instead of 1 0 and 0
1 we would do
0.5 0 and
0.5 let me press enter and see what
happens there you go it indeed worked
and really this should have showed this
red vector get smaller and this blue
vector gets smaller but hopefully you
get the idea and so let me go or maybe
they just want to always show the what
we could kind of call unit vectors
but let's go back to the original and
now let's think about a rotation this is
an interesting one pause this video and
think about how you would rotate it if
you wanted to rotate this clockwise by
90 degrees
all right if you rotate clockwise by 90
degrees this red vector is no longer 1 0
it would become
it would become 0 negative 1. so let me
write that down 0
negative 1 and the blue vector would
then go to where this red vector is and
it would become 1 0. so let's see
if we did it
the right way i'm going to click enter
and there you go we got our 90 degree
rotation
and so i just gave you some examples of
how you can do a pure rotation a pure
dilation or pure reflection but you can
imagine you can also do combinations of
them by manipulating this matrix
accordingly and i encourage you to play
around you can do some exotic
transformations if you want let's see
what happens if i make this a one press
enter oh that's that's interesting what
happens if i then make this
a two oh that's interesting so notice
you can do all sorts of really
interesting linear transformation and
just as a reminder linear transformation
is one where the origin always maps to
itself and any lines are mapped to other
lines not necessarily the same line but
whatever it gets mapped to will still be
aligned